[Music]
welcome back to cbs
this morning many of us will be lucky
enough to spend this memorial day
weekend at the beach
in california swimmers will have lots of
company in the water
new drone images near los angeles show
an increasing number of juvenile
great white sharks swimming among people
and they are displaying some behavior
that you might not expect
we sent carter evans to find out what's
going on
getting in the water with great white
sharks seems like a
terrible idea i don't dare stand up on
this board
we're just off the coast of santa
barbara and within minutes
this shark is is so close i could almost
grab its dorsal fin it is right
underneath me
now scientists say that shark is not
interested in me or other people
watch this huge shark swim right up to
these unsuspecting children
and just swim away the population of
these great whites off socal beaches
is exploding i can only see it now
because i'm getting up high
if i were a surfer i'd be lying down and
i'd have no idea
it was underneath me oh my god oh my god
don't bite him
wedding photographer carlos giona
started capturing these
stunning images off the beach last year
when the pandemic dried up business
almost every time i see an interaction
with a human and a shark
my heart does pound we've all been
conditioned ever since jaws came out
to fear that interaction but this
is far from jaws watch as a large shark
calmly cruises the surf line up this one
approaches a family
and a swimmer is headed right toward
another
all of the sharks seem uninterested
despite the fact that people are out
there thrashing around and their arms
are hanging off boards
and legs are hanging off boards sharks
just ignore it
chris lowe is director of the shark lab
at cal state long beach
why don't they want to eat us well we
don't really fully know the answer to
that question
first of all we're not close to being on
the menu most of the sharks spotted off
southern california beaches are juvenile
great whites
despite their size they're only up to
about six years old and very
inexperienced hunters take it off lowe's
team
showed us where the sharks used the warm
coastal waters
as a nursery when they're born they're
completely on their own
the safest place for them to be is in
shallow water they have to learn to feed
on what's there and the number one thing
that's there
are stingrays carlos's video shows that
they're very aware the surfers are there
yeah
in fact we've been able to document
sharks recognizing
that somebody's nearby so they know the
sounds of a person swimming and surfing
so they've learned that we're not a
threat it kind of seems that way
but lowe says that could change if
people get too comfortable and start
going
after the sharks they're a wild animal
and if they feel threatened they will
defend themselves
in 2019 the coast guard had to airlift a
surfer who was bitten by a shark
off santa rosa island but lowe says
unprovoked great white shark attacks
around here
are extremely rare i mean we're
essentially telling people here don't
worry about the baby great whites
in the water but does the same thing
apply on the east coast
actually no there we have adults that
are there to feed on seals
and those seals are sharing the beach
with people
so that's a very different situation
even in northern california
i'd be a lot more hesitant about getting
in the water but off the socal coast
this shark is just swimming so calmly
and so gracefully right now
lowe's team is working to eventually
predict the conditions that could lead
to encounters between sharks
and people i'm kind of hoping in about
five years
you'll get a rip current report and
you'll get a shark report
lo and his team say these videos and my
interaction
are examples that humans and great white
sharks
can co-exist at least in southern
california
for cbs this morning carter evans santa
barbara
no but i've heard people who work with
sharks say this that they're not really
dangerous
but it's hard to understand when you see
the shark attacks and people missing
limbs
that you shouldn't fear them but it
shows that if you don't
why do they come after us because they
think we're food well usually what
happens is they
they the swimmer is making an emotion
that
that churns up water like seals do and
sharks think
that we're a seal that's that's usually
the the excuse you hear
but they don't actually shark attacks do
not happen very often right
that's the key that's the key part of it
we're a far bigger threat to sharks than
they are to us i mean that's been said
yeah many times but
the video that video was interesting to
see how calmly they said
even with your feet in the water all
with people all around them